last year the town of Celoron New York
was accosted by a monstrous gobbler of
souls Lucille Ball tribute statue which
the townspeople quickly named scary Lucy
that made by Barbara that's not with
y'all right now you may remember that we
launched a campaign to bring scary Lucy
here to the @midnight stage which
coincidentally is where I Love Lucy was
filmed the first thing I feel like we
are 100% living up to the comedy I can't
even say it with a straight face I can't
even say that with a straight face
anyway one of our fans put this sign on
her let @midnight have this statue bring
Lucy home was the hashtag we sent two of
our guys over there they went to a town
hall meeting they were like can we have
that we have that horrifying thing that
you can't do anything with and they were
like mm it's now a year later they
finally replaced scary Lucy with this
new beautiful statue
this is Botox Lucy I don't know if I
like it
never doing a Botox this is the kind of
lady who would body shame scary Lucy it
kind of feels like there's a they
captured the feeling of what it was like
to be married to desi anything now since
we tried to get the statue from Celeron
and they wouldn't give it to us
what can the horrifying scary Lucy
statue be used for now
Beth Tim Burton's fluffer yes boy all
right Larry King's next wife drill a
hole in mouth I'll take it